上周正好有点事情 然后两周吧
这两周其实市场收到很大的geopolitical
就是以色列和伊朗这个冲突的一些影响吧
然后其实我想先说的一件事情的是
那个Fatmetic
就是在这两周上周有点事情
然后两周吧
这两周其实市场收到很大的geopolitical
就是以色列和伊朗这个冲突的一些影响吧
这是那个Fatmetic
那个美联储的一个态度
其实我们当然美联储是在这个最近
它一方面在那个特朗普的关税政策
一方面又是受到这个
全球的这些政治影响的情况下
看了这个美联储会
那么这会上呢
我觉得用一个词来形容吧
它是故意的非常小心
对于特朗普关税未来的一个政策走向
对于美国经济增长和那个统长
它都是故意非常小心
所以基本上给出的是
今年降两次的中间化的预期
就是我们说的就是10比9吧
10个委员对9个委员
这个Fat.是10对9
然后今年可能会降两次
它对于那个tariff的这个预估
其实比我们要小一点
就是如果我们按照这个Glomasex
高盛的预期的话
高盛是觉得那个tariff会增加14%
Effective tariff增加14%
但是有一些likely的
就是我们觉得有可能会发生的
还没有完全发生
那现在我们把那个
之前的那些tariff
就是关于对于中国的
包括现在90天的暂停的
都设定为最低限
就是它现在是怎么样就怎么样
说跟中国不会再增加
那个这个情况下
大概现在是10%
所以其实Fat pressing的
大概也收拾这个数字
那么他们对于GDP增长
其实GDP增长下调了
大概零年级吧
然后对于inflation的上升
上调零年级
但是它的整体对于tariff的
对于关税的这个预估
不是非常激进
但是J-PAL在那个会后
讲了4次
就是人家问到他
关于联储的这个联储
现在
现在的利率的情况
到底是怎么样
他说we are in a good place
说了4次
就是意思就是
我们的利率政策不会改变
我们现在利率
在一个很好的双方下面
应对可能会发生的这个关税
可能的通胀的上升
然后可能的经济
经济可能会走漏
那么我们现在这个情况
我们现在利率政策非常好
就是这个是他说4次
所以
引用一下高盛对于
那个今年的利率的预期
我觉得这还是一个比较
比较reasonable
我觉得比较合理的一个预期
就是今年可能会降一次
但是未必像高盛预期的
这么这么这么悲观
他们是觉得
大概12月份才会降一次
我是觉得可能9月份之后
有可能会降
就是如果要降
也要等到9月份之后
那个
不好意思
我前两天
有点生病了
那个
这个跟JPOW讲到
他说那个
就是
美国的关税
会对于consumer price
造成一些mini full的影响
它是就是有实际性的影响
这个也是他会后讲的
所以这个实际性的影响
大家会认为是什么时候来的
对于那个联储
他们认为
Summer就是夏天以后
其实很多投行的预期
也是要在这个时候
我们之前也说过
就是你对于所有的
那个关税政策
它是3月份
比较说4月份发生的
就4月份发生的
那它真正的影响要半年
或者是对通照影响
可能要3月到半年
所以无论如何
也到了这个Summer以后
大家才知道
这个反弹的物价反弹
大概会在一个水平
什么水平上面
那么确实
现在这一轮的物价反弹
和那个疫情的时候的物价反弹
是不一样的
疫情的时候
连着工资在一起长
所以它是工资螺旋在身
这个东西是很难止住的
但是关税的这个物价反弹
它其实更多的是Goods
就我们叫做Goods and Service
然后再加上那个房租
那么房租没有看到商商
然后Service
其实我觉得更多的
和以后的移民政策相关性
会比跟关税政策相关性更大一点
然后但是Goods
确实是会在今年
下期的时候会发生
所以这可能是一次性的
那么不会像上一轮
这么严重的螺旋上升
但是大家就是美联储
还是现在看来
还是会继续关注这个事情
那么如果说这种情况下
我觉得9月份以后
才可能会降息
所以今年中卫数的预期
是加两次
那么26年27年的这种预期的降息
其实我们不用太关注
这种狼狗称不用太关注
因为本身也不是很准
其实我们更
看发到更加重要的事
就是一年或者是半年
他们大概的这个
美联储的预期在怎么样
联储不同于狼狐
也不同于比方说中国的政府
他们是希望给到市场
一个比较准确的预期
所以在长期里面
可能不是特别准
但是在短期里面
就是几个月里面
这个东西还是挺准的
就是他们一般会按照
这个比较代表联储
现在的看法
那么我也关注到
就是说
昨天好像联储有几个月
出来说
说我们4月7月份
就应该降一次息
但是这个肯定
我看推特上挺多的
这肯定不代表联储的态度
联储的态度是非常清晰的
就是主席和投票委员的DOT
他们是认为
今年要比较谨慎
就是故意的
我们叫做故意的谨慎
不管是对于
这个换税政策
或对于可能
自由political
各种各样自由political
Tension
他们要做好
他们要故意的谨慎
所以呢
这个降息的幅度
在今年和明年
我觉得不会特别大
那如果说明年的话
明年可能会降两次
它三次
今年年初的时候
我们本来是觉得
今年可能降三次
甚至甚至会更多
至少要降三次
但是当关税出来
关税是降低GDP
升高通胀
一旦它有升高通胀
这个影响的情况下
人主就不太会行动了
所以把那个降息的次数
可能会减到一次到两次
明年又变成一次到两次
本来明年可能也是四次
所以通胀确实是一个
更大的影响
其实从
财政之初上来说
也是这个样子
就是说
为什么我们
我们之前讲到
就是政府在我周期的一件事情
就是政府在我周期的过程当中
其实大家对于
资金的使用的需求会增加
就是说
Quality这个东西
在私营部门的增加
远远级不上在政府层面增加
政府层面去年
是增加大概10%
那么这个东西
就整个Quality Growth
新代增加
带动了经济的增加
NormalGDP5%
那私营部门增加1-2%
在我们看到美国新的
这个我们叫
Big Beautiful Bill
大美利法案
它其实基本上
Physical Package出来以后
我们会看到
虽然说那个
就是我们叫做
赤字的
Defensive Versus GDP
这个数字和过去
基本上保持一致
但是我们会看到
未来10年
它的那个DatGDP
就债务VersusGDP
会继续增加
就是说
大家担心美国的是说
我在一个什么样的时点上
会走路一个不归路
就是相当吸毒一样
我这个也是接不掉了
那么可能就在
现在这个时点就接不掉了
但是这个远远不代表的
就说美国会产生货币问题
或者是债务通缩问题
债务和货币问题
在美国不太会
这个事情
我们之前好多次
我其实有讲过
那么美国国内
有很多的担忧
美国国内有很多的担忧
其实是关于
美国能不能
就财政上能不能继续自主
就是我是不是以后要
依靠通胀了
是不是以后要依靠硬钱了
能不能自己把这东西走过去
那么这个
Beautiful Beautiful出来以后
我们上次看到的就是
它不会了
就是可能走到一个临界点
之后它会
我们叫
其实在这个之前
其实pandemic
我认为其实
不是现在
而是pandemic的时候
就已经开始走到一个临界点了
那么
特朗普政府只是
延续了拜登政府
之前做的事情
就是你看这个physical package
就新出了physical package
虽然说赤字
会比过去低那么一点
但是现在利率更好
不管你是因为tariff
或者什么原因
通常相对高一点
利率也会相对高一点
所以整个财政赤字
基本上维持在跟过去
不变的水平上
百分之五比利品
那么
这个过程大概
这个程度大概跟
0809年中国市场的
那么在这个之后
你可能就没有办法再回头
财政赤字会越来越多
后来会越来越依靠货币
虽然美元不会在短期里面
就至少十几年
不太会产生货币问题
但是未来十年里面
你会看到
data GDP的比率
不停地上升
那么
这个过程里面
real interest rate
现在跟过去的差别
就是说
第一个
data GDP level
会变得更高
但是real interest rate
利率水平也更高
所以
尽管不觉得
会有货币危机
但是以后这个事情
会对美国政治
有很多的影响
就是每一次大选的时候
都会出来说这个事情
就是我们
国家借账都在怎么办
然后
dassilin以后
会一直要突破
一直要出
市场会对这个
一直也会有担心
然后
也有可能吧
就是等到
这轮不会吧
可能再等
等五年十年
那么到时候要看
我到时候是
财政的整合
还是会产生一些同仗
因为这个东西
最终是要有人买单的
你印钱也是买单
你比方说
你印钱发债
你用那个连储区
更多的去买美债
也是买单
所以这个就是
我们认为是
美国走进财政的周期
但是财政周期对于资产
不一定是件坏的事情
财政周期本身
对于经济增长
是个很好的事情
就我们看08年
中国
08年到
15年的中国增长怎么来的
都是
其实很大程度上
是财政
财政周期带动
带动经济一起增长
那么
中国后面出的问题
其实有其他原因
有人口的原因
有一些其他政策的原因
那么并不是说
这个财政周期在15年之后
如果继续进行下去
它进行不了
而且中国人民币的
这个地位和美国
还是很不一样
所以
我觉得
physical package 来看的话
整体不会
现在肯定是
整体不会太悲观
那么
就是
我们要关注的一个点
就是这个section 899
因为section 899
可能会
导致后面的
就是这两件事情
是联合在一起的
我们叫tax和
税和那个
税和那个贸易谈判
其实两件事情
是合在一起的
首先就是
三个月的这个
Trader
Trader 威胁
差不多快要到期了
所以你回看美国
跟哪些国家
Trader 会比较大
就是中国
日本 越南 欧洲
中国现在基本
谈了差不多了
就跟美国应该
我们认为
它会有更大的变故
现在看上去两边
好像是
表面上是谈好了
后面出不出裂痕
有可能
但表面上
还可以
然后日本的短期
利贸易的谈判
是没法推进的
因为日本是需要
三万手行选举
所以他很难跟美国
在选举前
达成一个什么样的协议
那么
其实大家比较关注的
就是欧洲
那欧洲跟美国谈判
其实很多都是
税联动的谈判
我们就叫Saxon 899
就是美国要征收关税
美国要对
对美国公司和企业
征收不平等
税收的国家征收关税
所以欧洲
确实有很多乱七八糟的税
然后说什么
Digital Service Tax
什么之类的
这个我们上周
可能讲过吧
就是DST这些
那么DST这些东西
谈判的
其实很多是需要报
这在加拿大也有
就是欧洲和加拿大
他要跟美国进行
双边税务谈判
这个过程是很长的
所以市场未开始慢慢担心
就是9月
特朗普给的这个周期到了
是不是会给欧洲一个
比如说一个下马位
那我个人觉得
就是因为动欧洲
就是对市场冲击
会非常非常大
那这个其实
甚至你可以看
这一轮关税
这轮关税美国最早
开始对中国加税
市场影响没有那么大
虽然中国是美国最大的
就是其实最大的出口
对于通胀影响应该是很大
但是没有影响特别大
等到他给大家都加了关税
以后就一下子就崩掉了
那么如果说动欧洲又开始
就说我又没有弹楼
然后又开始要
比方说加关税什么的
那么这些
会对市场冲击会很大
所以我个人觉得
特朗普现在不太会
特朗普
我们上上周讲过一个事情
Taco
就是我觉得现在
主义了太后的状态
就是他不太敢去让市场
承担太大的波动
包括他
我们大伙讲一下
那个以色列和伊朗的事情
那么他整体的话
我觉得他不太
不太愿意去让市场承担
就是太多的下地
所以包括上次的
上次的那个关税政策
出来之后
他很快也把他收回了
所以希望他
不会产生太多的东西吧
那么
狗们这边预期
还有25%的一些
就是
板换性的太
这可能会陆续带出来
那么但是
可能不一定是
针对欧洲这种
比较说
坦崩掉的这种
这种谈判
所以3899
这个事情是双边的
然后一方面
会减少
各个国家对美国的投资
如果他继续这样搞的话
会减少各个国家对美国投资
第二方面
他和关税这两个东西
其实是要联动的
那么
然后我讲一下
那个伊朗的事情
因为我觉得伊朗
其实对油价影响
看上去是非常大的
就是
那个从上上周
在七八天前吧
然后以色列去
大家可能新闻上
都看到了
以色列袭击伊朗
然后来信
他发动的这个袭击
然后其实他
他政策上非常聪明
他把那个
他把那个伊朗的
那些教室集团
炸到了那个
地下办公室里面去
然后他把伊朗的
那个革命卫队的
领导人基本上
全部给看掉
然后把伊朗的总参谋长
相当于陆军
陆军总参谋长
干掉
然后任命心的再干掉
其实让那个
帕美尼伊的感受是
我只能做一个独裁者
我只能躲在地堡里
然后我最亲近的人
在地上都被杀
然后我有可能
对这个政权
丧失控制
我非常恐惧
所以其实今天早上
其实今天早上
你看这个油价
跌了很凶
其实今天早上
其实说伊朗和那个
以色列要进行
忘了是六个小时
十二个小时的停火
然后这个是
川普的出诉手
我今天一大早看到
川普出诉手发的
所以对于
伊朗的教室集团
他们这种独裁政权来讲的话
它其实非常恐惧的
因为并不是说
我打了核战争
我躲到地下井
然后上面人都被打死
然后我继续跟敌国开战
还是说上面老百姓都没事
我的那些虾兵谢将
全部被搞死了
全部被杀死了
然后我一个人
要躲在地下
地下那个核设室里面
然后还有可能
会被专地单打
然后我的那个联系的
上面的人被打死以后
我对上面局势
可能会丧失控制
其实也看出来
以色列和美国说
要颠覆他的政权
其实没有颠覆政权的需要
他就是要把它核设室打掉
那个伊朗和美国谈
那个和不够暂调的谈判
然后特朗普给了
六十天宽限期
六十天宽限期一到
以色列就发动
对伊朗的吸睛
这次其实
以色列把伊朗的
基本上
所有的防空设施
全部炸掉了
有的是从内部发无人机打
有的是从导弹打
有的是飞机打
然后那个
以色列飞机
基本上完全占领伊朗伤口
然后炸弹
然后在
应该是周末的时候吧
美国用了这个专地弹
因为以色列
没有这个武器
美国用了专地弹
把伊朗的核设室
可能离经济给炸掉了
但是
反正现在还没有看到
有核物支出来
虽然伊朗把原料
可能给拿掉了
但是
这个事情的结果
我感觉就是
告诉伊朗
你就不能再发展核设室
或者是
以色列和美国
是不能容许伊朗这样的国家
就对以色列敌对国家
拥有核武器
但是
对于市场来讲
其实是个利好
你可以看到
原油大部分的上涨
都是在
Tension Build Up的时候
就是
它不是伊朗在谈判
一直没谈好
Tension在Build Up
觉得要打没打
可能要打的时候
但是当以色列一旦开战
其实以色列开战
既得利
马上就开战
却要打赢了
之后油价
其实就没有涨过
这个涨就是
以色列开战的时候打的
打的
就开战那几天打的
涨的
涨完以后
这几天战争期间
油价基本上保持平稳
美国炸完
液盘
确实涨了一点
就是美国
在这里炸的
就先几天晚上炸
炸完就涨了一点
包括在
昨天
昨天白天
美国白天的时候
交易的时段
油价也没有在上涨
它其实一直在下跌的
这个路径中间
就是震荡性的下跌
也就是说市场
其实并没有把
特别当回的事情
包括你可以看到
以色列的股市也在涨
就是这几天
以色列股市也是在
也是
也是没有怎么下跌
在上涨
就昨天
好像也是在上涨
就是即使
它的导弹打到了
莫萨德的基地
即使它的导弹
砸到了太郎
维护砸到了几个
那么
但是这个
对于以色列人感受
我在以色列之前
投过不少项目
然后
包括我和以色列
很多创业公司的CEO的沟通
他们心还是很奇的
然后还是非常非常乐观
他们就觉得这些
就是对于
我对敌人造成的伤害
他们打过来的东西
可能
无所谓
就是这个没有道理的东西
也确实那么
伊朗在美国袭击之后
其实今天早上
今天早上的时候
就是昨天晚上
美国时间早上
他攻击了美国的一个军事设施
好像在巴林的一个军事设施
事先还通知了美国
让美国全部跑完
不要把美国人打死
然后象征性的攻击之后
就宣布了
这个12小时
6个小时的停火
所以短期里面
肯定是一个对市场
比较利好的
就是很多事情
就像这种
不爆发在incrubate
在累积的时候
对市场影响相对是最大
当它争了爆发了
被解决了
或者这种
就是伊朗的问题
看上去好像
我们拖了几十年
没有解决
从奥巴马政府开始
从之前就开始说
伊朗和问题
现在好像被炸掉了
那么市场反而是一个relief
但是伊朗之前
发布过一件事情
它说它要去封锁
或者这么自海峡
它要把那个伊朗海峡封锁
就是我们现在看上去
伊朗的危机
就最坏的时间已经过去了
但是如果伊朗回头
再去争了把这个海峡封闭
我看有很多评论觉得
这个主要的这个
原由是运给中国的
运给欧洲的
对美国影响不大
那其实不是的
因为你想
如果把海峡
争的给封闭掉以后
我们认为
每天会减少
15到17个million barrel
1500万桶
到1700万桶
这个石油的供应
美国每天
如果说美国
每天重新增加供应
能增加多少
就市场你说
那个供应面减少了
它去增加供应能增加多少
可能在几十万桶吧
就是美国之前关掉的
增加的供应几十万桶
你所有地方
俄罗斯的供应
没有办法流入到市场
俄罗斯有很多富裕的产能
你到不了市场上去
所以这个17
15到17个million barrel
90%是没有办法被满做的
就它如果真的能够
就第一个它想
第二个它真的有能力
把那个海峡给关闭的话
那么这个油价
就必须要靠
全球的这个
战略储备来稳定
除了战略储备
没有东西
可以稳定这个东西
就是它这个
可以轻松的
把原油价钱
推到一半以上
那么战略储备
全球有多少
美国有400亿桶
400米岭
中国有400米岭
然后比较多的就是
比方说日本250个米岭
用三个月吧
就是如果把海峡
真的关掉
大家用三个月
就是战略储备都会好解
所以这是
其实说到
你要去把海峡关闭的话
是一件非常严重的事情
就是它
因为受到袭击
就是受到美国袭击吧
美国把他那个
地下河设施
这些地方炸掉
炸掉以后
它第一个反应
就是说我要去把那个
我要去
我要去把那个
河泽沐测海峡也关闭掉
但是
如果是真的去关闭海峡的话
那么对全球的影响
不管是对原油层面
对各方面影响
对对对对都非常非常大
看到油价
其实昨天下跌
就是市场pricing的
这个
其实在昨天
它宣布要干
这个市场pricing
它都不会干
就是
如果真的做到的话
那就是一百到一百二十之上
就到这个价钱
那么这是一个
然后
最后说一个吧
就说那个
还有一个就是
Tesla
Tesla上周日的时候
出了那个Robotex
那么我再找
我再说一下
Tesla这个公司
其实他一直有一些
他有很多很好的科技
他而且
我是一个非常非常看好公司
那么这个公司
意识拿一些东西
就是引着市场往前走
Robotex是Tesla在
本轮下跌之后
上涨到重要的原因
因为都知道
它6个方向发布
确实我觉得
是很强的
那么
但是从Robotex
走到FSD
就真正的我的FSD的系统
就是无人驾驶系统
然后这个系统以后
我可以给到
更多的车厂用
其他的车都能用
我觉得
中间的Hardware
它的那个硬件
可能还是需要进步的
也就是说
Tesla现在做了很牛逼的
一件事情出来
然后
但是呢
它业绩经历不会特别好
所以我们之前讲到
就是Tesla的
可能当腾没有走完
我觉得
现在当腾未必
就是现在未必是一个
当腾
今年当腾完全走完的
一个状态
更多的是
大家对于Tesla
就今年的预计
在这个点上沸腾了
就是催化级都催化了
那么在今年后面
它还有些什么催化级呢
比方说
年底的时候
它会出Hardware 5
Hardware 5
拿Tape out
可能到明年吧
本来计划可能今年年底
但Tesla经常也会delay
所以可能到明年
但是
商业化这些东西
然后把FSD也商业化
Robotex也商业化
然后带来Revenue
带来收入
这个可能没有那么快
也就是说今年
它的收入不会特别好
这个是我对Tesla的品牌
我觉得Tesla这个公司
如果你们要拿着
是一个非常非常好的公司
然后整个AI
是让美国
就资本市场
和全球资本市场
不一样的
一个很重要的原因
就是一方面是AI
第二方面是
美国的Household
基本上都在买股票
美国股票
美股里面
最多的侯应
其实不是Household
Household在2%到3%
大部分都是Household
都是老百姓
那么他们的财富
其实都累积了
包括401K
都在那里
都是在股票里面
但是美股Differentiate
跟欧洲Differentiate
一个很重要的原因
是中间的高科技
它的AI
那么AI里面
你最重要能够实现
能够让它变成
一个可用的东西
现在前端可用的
其实不是特别多
那么机器人
和无人驾驶都是
这个特斯拉占了两个赛道
它很强
但是B-Inside它很强
在AI赛道中
它是个明星
但是它短期里面
业绩不会太好
就今年年底前
业绩可能是在一个低谷上
特别它是坐车
车这个东西
会越来越多受到
上次好像有讲过
越来越多的受到
中国车厂的竞争
中国车厂
就是中国
像个炼鼓一样的
炼出来一些
非常非常非常非常非常
这个卷的车厂
那么包括特斯拉
在中国的
销量也占它全球20%
并不小的
所以业绩
可能会在短期里面
对特斯拉有压力
但是
Robot taxi本身
我觉得是很厉害的
而且是代表的以后的
这个
以后的这个
无人驾驶
代表着无人驾驶的方向
比方说它比Wemo
成本要低很多
就是这个Tesla
又视觉的
识别的东西
甚至我一直觉得
它的FSD是可以用到
其他各个车厂的
这个
不光是电动车
包括这个
Hybrid
就是我们叫有电车
以后其实
各方系统
都是可以用到
这个Tesla
那个东西上面去的
所以
这个票你们可以
继续关注一下
但是我觉得短期里面
它的Catalyst
它的那个
最华级有点太强了
好吧
我大概简单这样介绍一下